ryan gosling is giving us a rare glimpse
inside his family life with ava mendes
and their two daughters esmerelda and
amada in a new interview with bridge gq
ryan referenced his watch partnership
with tag huber saying time in general is
something i think about a lot now my
kids are going up so fast i need to keep
an eye on the clock in a way i never
used to partnering with tag also
signifies that for me
and during the pandemic ryan explained
we have two kids so we spend a lot of
our time trying to keep them entertained
our kids were at a difficult age not to
be able to see other kids and interact
with people
even though ava and i did our best as
for the homeschooling aspect ryan could
relate as he was homeschooled for a year
as a child he admits it really did turn
things about for me i had a great
teacher though my mother was so good at
it she became a teacher she was the
perfect person to ask
excuse me
perfect person to ask for help when we
needed it i have not been doing shots i
promise
that's just now listen so i get excited
whenever you know i'm a huge fan of ryan
gosling yeah um and you know it's funny
i always think of like the ryan's like
ryan gosling yeah um ryan reynolds vine
reynolds and there was a time when ryan
reynolds was also very private but now
he's he talks more especially since he's
been with blake lively about their life
but ryan gosling has still maintained a
lot of privacy yeah he doesn't do a lot
of red carpets with ava mendez they
don't have like fun banter you know like
the other ryan and blake lively do um so
whenever he talks about his life i'm
always like clicking the link or
anything because i'm just so curious
yeah he keeps it private he has a
fantastic sense of humor he does very
very funny guy but i do respect their
desire to keep their lives out of the
public eye especially with their kids
and
it's very easy to get caught up in
everything and have people invade your
privacy right um
but i think that the funny story that
the homeschooling story i think is
really funny because i have an anecdote
about ryan gosling yes my i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna say it out now she cause
she tells this story this is not like a
private story she tells a story i get
together and stuff but my mother-in-law
is a teacher used to be a math teacher
math teacher and she taught ryan
math in high school that is crazy have
you always known this i've always known
this and so she she tells a story about
how
um one day she was kind of like
kind of scolding him about like not
studying for a math test or not doing
some homework or something or other and
he said well you know i had an audition
so i didn't do it my agent said it was
okay
and she goes well i mean your agent
isn't here and i'm your teacher i'm
saying you need to do this because i
know you want to be an actor but you
know if that doesn't work out you gotta
you gotta study you gotta do your
schoolwork and then she will always say
i was wrong turns out he turned out okay
he turned out pretty good hold on the
acting thing worked
that is such a cool story did he like
great story did she like him as a
student yeah yeah
well he's canadian i for some reason i
always forget that he was part of the
iconic mickey mouse club yeah you know
and he got like britney spears in there
christina aguilera and carrie russell
like just being a part justin timberlake
like you forget that you know
a young canadian kid yeah the part is
something so big like that there you go